gop governors are causing havoc
by bussing migrants to the east coast
that's a headline in yesterday's new
york times which is really confusing to
me because for years now i have been
reliably informed by the entire
establishment press and probably by the
new york times most of all
that the mass influx of illegal aliens
across our southern border into red
states
is totally awesome
that it's a major benefit to the border
states and to the whole country
that it's our strength i am told
but now
now i'm being told that a minor influx
of those very same illegal aliens into
blue cities
is causing havoc
how does that work
the new york times writes quote a
political tactic by the governors of
texas and arizona to offload the
problems caused by record levels of
migration at the border is beginning to
hit home in washington as hundreds of
undocumented migrants arriving on the
governor's free bus rides each week
increasingly tax the capital's ability
to provide emergency food and housing
but hold on wait wait
problems
hold on i've been told for years that
illegal immigrants don't use up public
resources that they are net contributors
to the economy
so how is it that the busloads of
immigrants are taxing washington dc's
quote ability to provide food and
housing they should be bringing their
own food they should be able to to
afford their own housing their their net
contributors right
that's what the libs tell us when the
illegal aliens show up to the red states
what changed the piece concludes with
the sad story of a 22 year old illegal
alien named juan who said he felt
unwelcome in liberal washington dc
without any money or any way to support
himself
he ended up in a homeless shelter but he
said quote the guys were yelling at us
and we couldn't understand a word it was
clear they didn't want us there again so
so weird
because texans and arizonans and all the
other americans along the border have
been clear that they don't want more
illegal immigration they don't want
people being trafficked by criminal
cartels into their communities bringing
crime and drugs and all sorts of bad
stuff it's always been the democrat
politicians
in washington dc
who have encouraged these foreign
nationals to pay off the cartels and
often go into debt with the cartels and
enter into our country illegally
but turns out those democrats don't want
the illegal aliens either
they just want to use the illegal aliens
to weaken red states to cause havoc and
after decades of this abuse at the hands
of the libs
the red states are finally sending the
havoc back to them i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music who says they
had a molecular biologist testifying
during a senate hearing and they didn't
even ask him and by the way dr ebright
what is a woman very disappointing that
is very disappointing i'm really upset i
want to call up dr ebright and ask him
that question i want to get him on the
record and when i call him you know i'm
going to be using puretalk right now
head on over to puretalk.com enter promo
code knowles byte inflation has left
every business trying to nickel and dime
you they're all trying to figure out how
much they can squeeze you to offset
their increasing costs
not pure talk that's why i love pure
talk pure talk drew the line in the sand
they said stop screwing over the
american public when you sign up with
pure talk this month you are going to
get their best offer yet you are going
to get one month
free just completely free you're going
to save probably two-thirds of what
you're you're currently spending on your
cell phone bill for all the talk all the
text all the data you want on america's
most reliable 5g network
you you're going to do all of that for
30 bucks a month except for that first
month where it's zero dollars a month
right now when you make that switch go
to puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
for this special offer do you need
another reason
when you choose puretalk you're choosing
to support american jobs not a company
that sends them overseas to china or
other places that hate us you're
choosing to support a veteran-owned
american-based company and most
important of all a sponsor of everything
we do here at the daily wire and the
sponsor of the voicemail bag which is my
favorite segment so head on over right
now to puretalk.com select a plan maybe
add a new iphone or android whatever you
want add promo code knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
get one month for free
speaking of strange headlines
we got a strange headline actually from
the daily wire it's not just the daily
wire though strange headline that's
coming from pretty much every news
outlet in the country and the headline
is this
wnba star brittany griner sentenced to
nine years in russian prison and i think
this is the first time that the daily
wire has ever published fake news
because they accuse us of publishing
fake news all the time i don't think we
have
until yesterday when this article came
out
because there is no such thing as a wnba
star right can't we all agree on that
regardless of what you think about the
brittany griner situation what's going
on in russia right now i think left and
right
should all we should all be able to
agree there is no such category as
wnba star
the only reason
that anyone has ever heard this lady's
name is because she's been arrested for
smuggling drugs into russia
and the only reason that anyone is even
talking about the wnba is because of
this international incident that was
prompted by this anti-american lady
athlete's
drug problem and her her trip to russia
to try to make money in an off-season
basketball league so brittany griner for
those who have not followed this story
and that includes me i didn't follow the
story until yesterday when this was
being blasted all over the headlines
brittany griner is a lady basketball
player she plays in the wnba and she the
wnba players because they don't make
very much money because nobody watches
the wnba they play in these leagues
overseas where they can make a little
bit more money and so she was playing in
some russian basketball games and she
flies over and she brings a bunch of
hashish oil
she brings a bunch of the distilled
essence of the devil's lettuce and this
is a big no-no in russia russia has much
much stricter drug laws than america
does i think most countries have
stricter drug laws than america does and
so she gets stopped and she's arrested
and she goes to trial and she was just
sentenced yesterday to nine years in a
russian prison
how are we supposed to feel about this
well i'll tell you
i'll tell you one of the things that
informed how i feel about this i googled
brittany griner i had obviously never
heard of her before and one of the first
things to pop up is this article from a
couple years ago in the washington post
brittany griner
and brianna turner call for the wnba to
stop playing the national anthem
this season because they don't they
don't like the national anthem the
national anthem is the star-spangled
banner the star-spangled banner is the
symbol of our entire country so i don't
i don't know any way to interpret
brittany greiner's actions a couple
years ago
i think through the present
other than she doesn't like america she
hates america
and she's playing in some foreign league
and then she breaks their laws and then
she comes running back begging america
to help her and i got to tell you
i'm not the well is dry here i'm trying
to muster tears for brittany griner in
her present predicament
they're not coming they're not coming i
just don't i guess
i guess generally i lean on the side of
it would be good to bring her home
i i'm
51 49 on that side because certainly
russia is going to use her for political
leverage to try to
either have a prisoner swap with america
or to try to put some political pressure
for america to ease up on some of the
sanctions or whatever so she is going to
be used as a political pawn but i'm
still 5149 here because i have to ask
myself this other question
does russia have a right
to make its own drug laws
i think so i think russia has a right to
make its own drug laws
are russia's drug laws being selectively
applied to this lady basketball player
no certainly not there's another story
no one's talking about this we're all
talking now about the lady basketball
player well just last month you you see
a story from this is right here in the
bbc
russia sentences u.s teacher to 14 years
for cannabis smuggling so it's the same
sort of issue here but because he's not
in a woke kind of sports league
no one's talking about him really in the
press you get one article here in the
bbc but this guy
was
he was discovered with his drugs at
moscow's airport in 2021
and he uh he was a i guess he was a
former us diplomat he's now teaching in
a school
and he brought in some pot same issue
that brianna or whatever her name is
brittany griner
was caught with here in russia
why are we talking about him maybe he'll
be part of some deal okay maybe
the other aspect of this so does russia
have the right to make its own drug laws
i think so yeah we have the right to
make our own drug laws other countries
have the rights to make their own drug
blows i think russia has the same rights
then the next question is
are russia's drug laws totally insane in
draconian i don't think so russia's drug
laws are just what the american drug
laws were like 25 or 30 years ago
when america's drug laws made a lot more
sense
do we think it's good that we have
liberalized all the drug laws and
encouraged people to take more drugs i
don't think that's good i think that's
really bad we've got the worst drug drug
overdose problem in american history
right now the problem is so acute that
the american life expectancy has
actually declined for the first time
ever but multiple years in a row and
it's declined because of deaths of
despair largely
we're talking about suicide and we're
talking about drug overdoses
major major issues especially with young
people overdosing on drugs i bet i know
people who in the last two three years
have overdosed on drugs people i thought
would never have a drug problem
i i'm
certain that the vast majority of you
know someone who's overdosed on drugs in
recent years opioids fentanyl whatever
so yeah i say i actually think russia's
drug laws make a hell of a lot more
sense than america's drug laws do
sometimes you'll hear people say well in
america
we throw people in prison for carrying a
dime bag of pot that's not true we
actually don't do that
we we barely throw drug dealers in
prison drug peddlers in prison and when
you allow drug dealers and drug peddlers
to operate you you poison the country
and you you enrich criminal cartels i
think it makes a whole lot more sense
what we see in russia
and so then you got to ask yourself why
am i shedding a tear for brittany griner
the only reason that she's even
appearing in the news is because she is
super woke and she hates america so
sorry lady cry me a river i'm just not
i'm just not there i think the lesson
that we should take from this here's a
psa for everyone out there traveling
overseas don't smuggle drugs into
foreign countries lesson number two
don't smuggle drugs into hostile foreign
countries lesson number three don't
smuggle drugs into hostile foreign
countries that have had nuclear weapons
pointed at the heads of you and your
countrymen for the last 70 years okay
that's that's my psa to everybody the
other lesson that we should maybe learn
here is
maybe we could learn a thing or two from
the way that other countries are dealing
with the drug problem before our entire
country overdoses on dope because we're
because we're a nation of dopes these
days not the regular american people but
the political leadership no question
about it when you want to protect
yourself when you want to protect
yourself from the predations of terrible
political leaders who are destroying the
economy you might want to check out
birch gold right now text knolls to
989898
the consumer price index has reached yet
another 40-year high the latest gdp
numbers confirmed that the united states
is in a recession despite the best
efforts of the current administration to
redefine what recession means we are
right this second in a recession take
action to protect your savings from a
highly turbulent economy right now by
diversifying at least some of your
investment portfolio into gold and
silver from birch gold group text knolls
k w l e s to 98989
and birchgold will send you a free
information kit on how to transition an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira in
precious metals birch gold will even
help you hold gold in a tax sheltered
account for decades investors have
relied on gold and silver as a hedge
against inflation now you can too here
we are here's the inflation with an a
plus rating for the better business
bureau countless five-star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers secure
your future with gold from birch gold
right now text knowles kennedy wles to
989898 get real help from birch gold
today that is knowles text it to 989898
claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
speaking of bad stuff to put in your
body
cracker barrel
no cracker barrel is not the bad stuff i
love cracker barrel the bad stuff to put
in your body in this context
is the fake sausage that cracker barrel
is is now peddling
cracker barrel had this post it went up
yesterday they said discover new meat
frontiers experience the out of this
world flavor of the impossible sausage
made from plants
next time you build your own breakfast
this story was brought to my attention
by aaron mcintyre
i i looked at this story i thought oh my
gosh this is
this is the most devastating argument
against the free market i've ever heard
in my life
this is devastating because there is no
way in hell that the
vegan vegetarian whatever fake sausage
cracker barrel is being driven by
customer demand
not one single person who has ever
walked into a cracker barrel would even
consider eating fake vegetarian sausage
not one
people who walk into cracker barrel
myself included tend to be a little
heartier a little more old school
sometimes a little more on the big bubba
side of things
what they would want if there were going
to be any change to cracker barrels
sausage they would want them to add more
meat to it they would want the sausage
to be pork and beef and probably veal
and they would just add as much meat as
possible okay this decision is being
driven
from the top
this decision is woke executives or who
knows the the kinds of people in in
front in the big funding
firms you know in whatever it is venture
capital in the public markets we're
pushing esg environmental social
governance policies they're the kind of
people who are saying we need to impose
these new standards the same people who
want us to live in our pods and eat the
bugs and not own anything and be totally
happy and stop driving cars and take
bicycles everywhere and take public
transportation these are the people who
say don't eat you don't get to eat your
sausage anymore you don't get to eat
meat now you have to eat impossible meat
yum yum it's so delicious that's where
those decisions are coming from this is
not a corporation responding to market
demand and unfortunately that's that's
the way that a lot of our
our market operates that's the way a lot
of our businesses operate this is why
though i'm a conservative and i have a
ton of respect for free markets and i
think free markets can be a good means
to an end for a flourishing society i do
not worship at the altar of the free
market okay
because i i know
one that free markets can be so easily
perverted and two it takes a political
order to set the parameters of a market
just like you think of a physical
marketplace that you go to a physical
marketplace has little roads and streets
and building codes and ways that it's
designed and that's that is established
by the political order well the same
thing holds true
in the economic market in the more
abstract market
and the fact is there are a lot of
activists out there who are manipulating
market forces to try to not respond to
customer demand but to change customer
demand and to turn us into a nation of
to use a popular phrase weak soy boy
betta cucks who were just we're just
eating a bunch of fake plant sausage
instead of good delicious pork sausage
like we were intended to eat so
i i certainly will never eat the
impossible sausage of cracker barrel
i've seen outrage from fellow cracker
barrel fans like i am and if those guys
know what's good for them they will get
rid of this vegetarian crap from the
menu because until they do
i am not stepping foot
back into a cracker barrel these woke
executives think they can force their
will on us i don't think so buster hit
him where it hurts right in the
pocketbook enough about sausage we have
to get to monkey pox there is a headline
in the washington post
about monkey pox here's the headline as
monkey pox strikes
gay men
officials debate warnings
to limit partners
what's the debate what's the debate here
they're admitting the washington post is
admitting monkey pox strikes gay men
virtually everyone who gets monkey pox
is a homosexual man and not even just
any homosexual man homosexual men who
have sex with lots of other homosexual
men
it's not even the ones who just have sex
with one homosexual man it's the ones
who go to bath houses and gay orgies and
all that kind of stuff
and so we know that is how it spreads
in virtually all cases that is how it
spreads but the officials are debating
whether or not to tell them not to do
that they're debating it is that well i
don't know a lot of people are saying we
shouldn't do that's not nice thousands
of this is the
first paragraph san francisco thousands
of gay men clad in leather latex and
often much less partied along folsom
street here last weekend
during the annual kink and fetish
festival
even after the city had just declared
the monkey pox outbreak striking its gay
community a health emergency one day
after the world health organization
urged men to sleep with fewer men to
reduce transition san francisco public
health officials made no attempt to rein
in festivities or warn attendees to have
less
sex
this is really the fact that these
festivals are even allowed to take place
is a national scandal
and
and
sometimes we say gosh the founding
fathers would be rolling over in their
graves forget the founding fathers
people who were alive during the clinton
administration
would be rolling over in their graves
pulling their hair out many of them are
okay it wasn't so long ago that this
sort of thing would be unthinkable
and now the public
officials and the media are debating
whether or not it is appropriate even to
suggest that maybe the guys who show up
to the leather kink fetish festival have
sex with slightly fewer men at the
festival to stop spreading a virus that
is spread almost exclusively that way
now
the the debate here the whole premise of
the article is that monkey pox
policy is being based on politics not
science and we talked about this
yesterday in a totally separate subject
on covid but the same thing holds true
here that's good
the debate actually is good it should be
in the realm of politics not of science
the libs
are unwittingly
at least engaging in the debate the
right way
because whether or not we want to have a
society full of leather kinky fetish
festivals
and orgies and
people stooping each other in the middle
of the street
that really isn't a scientific question
i don't care if fauci came out tomorrow
and he said
we sh we the science is in
the data are here leather kinky fetish
festivals are very good for public
health i well i wouldn't believe him
because he's dr fauci so i usually think
that whatever he says the opposite is
true but even if it were a scientist
that were credible i wouldn't care it's
not a question for the scientists in the
lab coats it's a question for us for we
the people in our political society and
i for one think that the reason that we
should encourage homosexual men to stop
having sex with multiple partners a day
at the at the
fetish festival in san francisco the
reason to encourage them to do that is
not just because they're going to get a
virus that shouldn't even exist in
america
that's one reason but the other reason
is it's bad for you don't do that
do we really want a society with the
leather festivals in the middle of san
francisco i don't i think that's bad i
think that should be discouraged i don't
think there's any constitutional right
to the leather kink festival i don't
think there's any natural right
to have sex with multiple partners in
the middle of the streets with a bunch
of leather daddies and all sorts of
weird weird eccentric sexual i don't
think there's no right to that
and in america we strongly discouraged
that for a very long time through our
laws and through our culture and through
our standards and through our taboos and
now
now not only do we tolerate it but we
celebrate it and isn't that crazy does
anyone seriously believe that the most
liberal-minded person listening to this
show right now the most totally pro lgbt
whatever you want to call yourself do
you really believe this sort of thing
should be celebrated
we should sell oh gosh norm mcdonald had
a whole bit on this about the pride
festival and sometimes parents would
show up to the pride festival
and you say look do i love my son
my gay son yeah i love my son do i
tolerate homosexuality yeah sure maybe
we'll tolerate homosexuality
but are you proud you show up to the
leather the leather kink festival and
you say i'm so proud of my son
gosh i'm so proud look at him there
getting dragged around by a leash by
three half-naked dudes gosh nothing
fills me with more pride than that
no of course not and we as a society
have some right to have some say about
that as well because we have something
called community standards
so i'm i'm glad that the officials are
debating this i'm glad that we're not
just taking a scientific explanation
let's debate it
let great i'm glad we opened up that
that debate
let's debate it i think it's bad for
everybody and and deviant and abhorrent
and we should just generally speaking
ban the leather festivals from the
middle of the street so that they don't
scare the horses or scandalize the kids
or the rest of the public too that's my
that's my side of the debate where do
you fall in i bet you i bet you
the vast majority of people
i bet you the vast majority of
reasonable homosexuals the vast majority
of everybody across all these
demographics would agree keep this crap
out of the streets to stop monkey pox
and also to stop
all
the decadence
speaking of politics and science
governor ron desantis just removed
a state attorney from office
he did this because
he had a state attorney who refused to
enforce the law and there are a few laws
here that the state attorney didn't want
to enforce
he did not want to enforce a law that
prohibits
transgender surgery for the kids he said
you know i'm very pro transing the kids
the governor and the state legislature
have outlawed transiting the kids well i
don't care screw their law i'm i'm going
to continue to support transiting the
kids and then the other one was
florida's abortion laws so now that
florida has more pro-life laws in place
the state attorney said he wasn't going
to respect those laws or acknowledge
them and so ron desantis came out and he
said all right you lost your job
the constitution of florida has vested
the veto power in the governor
not in individual state attorneys and so
when you flagrantly violate your oath of
office when you make yourself above the
law
you have violated your duty
you have neglected your duty and you are
displaying a lack of competence to be
able to reform those duties and so today
we are suspending
state attorney andrew warren effective
immediately
love this this is awesome this is
actually i would say
reagan-esque you can tell ron desantis
is modeling himself after two people
donald trump he's talking kind of
trumpian terms he even does the hands
sometimes and ronald reagan he's
ryan desantis has a little more polish
than trump does one of trump's charms is
that he's not polished at all ronald
reagan was much more polished and
desantis has a lot of that as well and
especially in this action here to fire
the state attorney it reminded me of
when reagan came out when the air
traffic controllers were illegally
striking
threatening american travel and national
security frankly and ronald reagan came
out they all thought he was going to
cave and give in to the union demands
and he said look if you don't show up
for work in a couple of days you're all
fired
it is for this reason that i must tell
those who fail to report for duty this
morning
they are in violation of the law
and if they do not report for work
within 48 hours they have forfeited
their jobs and will be terminated
at this point
what lesser action can there be the law
is very explicit
they are violating the law and as i say
we
call this to the attention of their
leadership whether this was conveyed to
the membership before they voted to
strike i don't know
but this is one of the reasons why there
could be no further negotiation while
this situation uh continues
you can't sit and negotiate
with a union that's in violation of the
law and their oath and their oath and
their oath well
well i'm gonna fire all those dirty
rotten commies
and then we're gonna hire up some more
we're gonna hire up some more ad traffic
controllers and all the rest of them can
go pound sand
and he does it with a smile but he's
very firm
ron desantis is doing the same thing you
don't do your job you're going to lose
your job simple as that
he's calling their bluff
in many ways it's a similar kind of
forcefulness it's a similar kind of
courage that you're seeing from those
governors in texas and arizona we talked
about at the top of the show saying
you're going to force illegal
immigration on us it's illegal first of
all and you're going to force it on us
and you think we're going to take it
we're not going to take it we're going
to send it to your backyard you deal
with it and what are the shrieks what
are the cries
this is
lawless
how ironic
people who are committing crimes and
people who are encouraging crime
accusing the people who are fighting
back against it of being lawless and
they'll say this is authoritarian this
is authoritarian of you governor abbott
it's authoritarian of you arizona's
authoritarian of you governor desantis
you guys
are
are exercising political power you guys
in the case of ron desantis you're
legislating morality on issues like
transgenderism and abortion and you know
what i say to that
you're you're darn right
yes that's true the the longer i live
the less convinced i am that the word
authoritarian means anything at all i
don't know what does it mean
today you're called authoritarian if you
say we shouldn't have leather kink
festivals outside of elementary schools
in san francisco
today you're called authoritarian if you
say maybe we maybe we discourage heroin
use on the streets oh you crazy
authoritarian what does that mean
what is it what does it mean what
authoritarian used to have a meaning
which is that you would unjustly and
capriciously and arbitrarily wield power
without any kind of reason whatsoever
but that's not what they're talking
about now they're just saying anytime
any conservative wields any political
power whatsoever he's an authoritarian
and it's just ridiculous doesn't mean
anything
and sometimes the conservatives accuse
the left of it you're authoritarian what
does that mean what does authoritarian
actually mean
it means you have a an idea that you
enforce in the public square
by that measure even the libertarians
are authoritarian
they're their insistence that we're not
allowed to have community standards
they're insistent that we're not allowed
to to do anything about drugs or weird
sex stuff or trancing the kids right
that that insistence is in itself
authoritarian
there is no way to escape
what is meant by this ridiculous use of
the word authoritarian these days which
is namely who has political power and
who wields it
the question is not are we going to have
political power
the question is who is going to have the
political power how is that political
power going to be wielded
and for for too long the right has said
we don't want it we don't want it we
don't want to use it don't make us do it
we're gonna have to do stuff we'll need
courage we'll need clarity we don't want
that and what has happened the left has
exclusively wielded power and it's
destroyed our culture
that's the question there was a hearing
yesterday
with the fbi director christopher wray
asking hey has anyone been disciplined
over crossfire hurricane the spying on
donald trump's campaign and the
undermining of donald trump's
administration all based on nothing
colluding with the democrats who wielded
power and you know what chris wray said
so it's kind of slowed down
can you give me an idea of anyone who's
been held accountable
uh who was involved in crossfire
hurricane investigation what specific
actions if any have been taken
well we've taken a whole slew of actions
in response to the cross for a hurricane
report i think over 40 plus corrective
measures anybody in the bureau there are
a number of disciplined there are a
number of people who are currently in uh
our what we call office of professional
responsibility which is our disciplinary
arm
you may wonder why has that not yielded
its results yet and that's because we
are working closely with cooperating
closely with and assisting the durham
investigation and so that whole process
which is not unusual uh has been sort of
slowed down to make sure that it doesn't
interfere with the durham investment
okay
let me translate that for you out of
deep state ease out of bureaucratis what
that means is yeah they're not going to
get in trouble
the people who
spied on the republican presidential
campaign and did everything they could
to undermine that campaign and get the
democrat elected working directly with
the democrats by the way and then the
people who undermine the trump
administration baselessly they're not
going to face any consequences we're
slowing down
in accordance with the usual rules of
the investigation of the blah blah blah
why because they've got the power
that's why because
power will be wielded there will be
order we talk about this very often when
it comes to questions of limited
government there will be order okay at a
certain point there will be order and
the question is will we govern ourselves
will we control govern ourselves both in
our personal behavior and in our
political life or will order be imposed
top down by people who are not very
accountable to us those are our options
you can't just have anarchy though
that's not going to happen
there will be order and there will be
power and the question is are we going
to give all the power to the deep state
are we going to give all the power to
the bureaucrats are we give all the
power to the scientists are we all those
scientific technocrats like voucher they
can have all the power or we can give
all the power to the democrats in
washington are we or are we going to use
justly some of the power that happily
the people occasionally give us and ship
those migrants those illegal immigrants
over to the democrat cities and say no
we don't want leather kink fetish
festivals on the streets of our american
cities and no we don't want drugs
everywhere and no we don't want crime
everywhere and yes we will have a good
flourishing country that's my whole
political ideology it's not it's not
left right this that here's my whole
political ideology i want a good
sane
normal country
that's it that's the ideology okay and i
think i think probably most people agree
with me on that is it ironic to make an
ad for an ad-free viewing experience
maybe
maybe it is but that's exactly the type
of experience you will get when you
subscribe to daily wire plus this is our
growing hub for all things daily wire
where you will find shows and podcasts
like this one and movies and bonus
content and coming soon kids content
daily wire plus is everything you love
about daily wire plus
so much more and minus the ads go to
dailywearplus.com become a member today
get 35 off your new membership that's
dailywireplus.com
now we get to my absolute favorite time
of the week that i've been waiting for
all week this whole sleepless week first
week with my newborn little second son
and i've just said the thing that's
keeping me going forget about the love
of my beautiful family forget about my
coffee forget about all you know you
know what's keeping me going knowing
that at the end of the week
i've got the voicemail back brought to
us by puretalk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code knowles podcast to get one month
free let's get to the first voicemail
bed question
hi michael my name is braden my pronouns
are he him i am wearing a sleeveless
shirt with short running shorts and i'm
about to go on a run i identify as white
but during the summer time people
misidentify me as tan
with the increase in lgbtq themes in
children's films i would appreciate it
if you could quickly expound on why this
content such as a gay or lesbian kissing
scene which would be similar to
something you would see between a disney
prince and a princess
is wrong this is one of those things
that feels wrong to me but i'm
struggling to explain to myself why i
appreciate it and again thank you so
much for your show
oh well this is easy it's wrong because
boys are supposed to kiss girls i think
are you asking why gay kissing seems
wrong to people
why people just have a kind of natural
reaction to it is because we know that
boys are supposed to kiss girls
this doesn't mean that we need to be
really cruel and mean to homosexuals
doesn't mean that homosexuals don't
exist and haven't always existed it just
means that's not normal that's not the
way things are supposed to be
things have purposes the leftist tears
tumbler has a purpose it's to carry
delicious salty leftist tears the
microphone has a purpose it's to
transmit my dulcet tones to you right
directly to your ears and our bodies
have purposes too
when we're talking about sexuality the
purpose of male sexuality is for women
and women's sexuality is for men and
they come together in marriage and the
purpose of that is the generation and
education of children
we can know this using the light of our
own reason from the natural created
world okay now this is a fallen world
things are a little crazy we've all got
things about us they're a little
eccentric and off-kilter and
gay kissing would be an example of that
something that's clearly off-center
off-kilter not not quite right
doesn't mean we gotta arrest these guys
it doesn't mean we gotta be really cruel
or ostracize them or anything like that
but
likewise we were talking about this
earlier in the show there's a difference
between
toleration
and celebration
there's a difference between
acknowledging that there are some weird
things in the world and there are some
things that are kind of
uh
off-center
and then putting those things right into
the center i was talking to a
friend of mine jonathan pageau the other
day and he
made this really really important point
which is if you look at medieval
manuscripts at the center you know
you'll see all these beautiful images
lots of really beautiful gold inlay and
obviously the text but then on the the
outsides and the fringes of of the page
you'll see these weird little strange
drawings of you know elves and and even
little drawings that are not quite
obscene but they're really kind of out
there
that's the way the world works there's a
center
there is a standard there is the way
things are supposed to be and then
there are things that are off-center and
wrong and aberrant and deviant and
that's part that's part of the world and
some are really really
wicked and evil and terrible and some
are just a little bit off and we use our
reason to perceive which is which that
that's why though and so the the issue
with putting you know prince charming
kissing the other prince charming in the
disney movie
is not that it's the worst most terrible
awful sin on the on the planet or
imaginable it's just that it's that's
not
that's not the sort of thing that stirs
people's souls and it's confusing and
it's off center and that's why we react
against that i'm just describing a
natural reaction okay that disney wants
to deny because putting sex completely
aside for a sec forget about the
homosexuals even putting all of sex
aside for a second the project of these
people who are
cultural marxists or social radicals or
the radical left or whatever you want to
call them the project is to redefine
reality
the project is to say here's the way the
world is i hate it i want to completely
change everything about it and i'm going
to redefine everything and and
the the wokeness that you're seeing in
disney is a part of that project all
right next question
hey michael long time listener
possibly converting to catholicism
because of all your infinite wisdom
here's my question
do you think the church has a role in
politics and here's what i mean i think
of mega churches that refuse to
chime in on cultural issues such as
abortion gay marriage whatnot they just
simply care about growing their
audiences reaching out to millennial
crowd i think of specifically in georgia
right now
two huge mega church pastors louis
giglio andy stanley refused to say
anything about the senate race going on
or the gubernatorial race with stacey
abrams
and then obviously like i said the
senate race with rafael warnock do you
think they have a role in saying
anything do you think they should be
preaching their congregation about the
who is the most
biblical candidate um because they they
really refuse to say anything andy
stanley in specific and georgia wrote a
book about not getting involved in
politics so
thanks michael again love the show
great question and the short answer is
yes of course the church has to be
involved in politics because the church
is a public institution
the church is not a private institution
in the sen when you say your prayers
alone at night and maybe you don't say
them alone maybe you pray with your wife
or your family but when you do have
private prayer
that is when
religion for you is private and it's
still not even private because you're
talking to someone you're talking to god
or maybe praying to the saints or maybe
but you could say okay right here in
this terrestrial plane that's private
but the church is where two or more are
gathered
when when christ is describing his
church on earth he's saying where two or
more of you are i am there also
and in our modern world where we're
obsessed with individualism
this doesn't make sense to us i said
what do you mean two or more why not
just one why not just me
you see this especially coming out of
the puritan tradition
uh i'm right now i'm reading pilgrim's
progress and a lot of my ancestors come
from the puritan tradition and the
puritan tradition is all about really
the individual relationship with god and
that's why it's had such an effect on
the modern world and especially in
modern america but that was kind of a
new idea and in my mind it's it's not
the correct idea of how to understand
christianity which is that we are in the
body of christ and we are it's where two
or more of us are gathered that's that's
really where we find our church and and
of course and and so the church's
mission is to make saints that's the
point of the church is to make
sure that you go to heaven and to to uh
work on your soul
uh but the church being a public
institution obviously has something to
say about public things and obviously
something to say about morality and
politics and and public are synonyms
political and public mean this the very
same thing and because all politics
ultimately is theological then if you're
not getting your
your moral ideas from the church you're
going to be getting it from somewhere
else and a
society based on the religion of leftism
is going to be a lot worse than a
society that comes out of your church
next
question hi michael thank you for
listening to my question
um so with all of the beyonce
controversy going on i thought now would
be a good time to bring up her
music video and i believe this is back
from 2008
it's called xo
and at the three minute and six second
mark
there's a flash of an actual demon
and it has nothing to do with the song
or the video
it's very scary and it's barely a second
long
i haven't heard anybody talk about it
and i don't understand why the word
spazz is so controversial but an actual
demon
that does not belong there
why is nobody talking about it
and also on her lemonade album
there's like a poem that she did
and there's a line in it that says
i
plugged my menses with pages from the
holy book
so that sounds like witchcraft to me
um i've also heard that she has lawsuits
due to severe witchcraft like her tour
mates or whatever said that she was like
using their kittens as sacrifices and
it's very scary so i just wanted another
pair of eyes on this to
maybe shine some spotlight on it and see
what the heck is going on with beyonce
so thank you again for taking my
question and have a blessed day
so i don't know about the
witchcraft kitten stuff but i do
remember the demon image
and it's really really weird if you
haven't seen this video it's just
beyonce just flashes a demon like an
actual demon just without any
any any reason that that would come from
the plot of the music video or anything
like that just flashes the demon there
and i have to tell you i'm not surprised
when that sort of stuff happens because
the devil is the prince of this world
because we're fighting against
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in the high places so when
when that that
peeks through the the veil a little bit
i'm not i'm not really all that
surprised
uh
demons are real the devil is real to
quote anton and scalia when he was
giving an interview to a very glib new
york magazine reporter
many more intelligent people than you
and me have believed in the devil okay
uh you you should have a healthy
caution
about
spiritual wickedness you you should you
should have a healthy fear of sin and do
your best not to sin because it's all
real okay it is all real c.s lewis makes
an important point too which is
sometimes when people
come to realize that good and bad are
are real things and the devil is a real
person and
people get really really interested in
that in the occult in and you're seeing
a rise in interest in the occult right
now
especially as public christianity wanes
and
c.s lewis gives good advice which is
you should
not you should not totally ignore
the fact that demons are real
you need to be aware of it
but you shouldn't be too interested
either
be aware of it know that it's real
be on guard
you know the devil is crouching in the
corner sin is crouching in the corner
waiting to pounce on you and gobble you
up at every given second we are living
in a world of intense spiritual combat
happening all around us and through us
uh
but don't harp on it all the time okay i
don't know what beyonce is doing i mean
she's had all sorts of weird
uh occult kind of imagery in her music
for a long time so i hope
you know hope things turn out okay for
her
but when as far as it pertains to you i
don't really care about beyonce all that
much though we do share a last name and
are probably cousins uh
you know as it pertains to you i
wouldn't focus on it too much uh just do
the right thing and
don't sin
don't sin and don't sacrifice any cats
and don't do whatever
beyonce allegedly did with the book and
all you know with the bible whenever
don't do that and just you know just
okay do the right thing next voicemail
bad question
you know michael you talk an awful lot
about being sicilian and swarthy
you know hairy and dark
well you're not that dark you don't look
that hairy you got the brown hair maybe
you got the brown eyes it's hard to tell
but you know i gotta question you you
say you're sicilian you say you're
italian but i just don't know i mean
come on what's knowles what was your
mother thinking marrying a guy named
knowles how italian are you really how
sicilian are you really
i gotta question you on that but you
know i wouldn't expect anything
different from a new yorker
anyway you can tell from the action
sincerely
a 97.5 italian from massachusetts
massachusetts yeah uh-huh really good
question some have wondered if knowles
is an anglicization from ellis island of
canole
though no in fact i am half wasp and
irish and then the other half is
sicilian and calabrese i would hope that
my for those of you who are only
listening to this right now i'm wearing
a black button shirt today
you know an oxford shirt i'm wearing a
sort of eggplant colored blazer i am as
close to al pacino as i'm ever going to
be
in this all right so what i would say to
you my friend from boston is please
forget about it one last question i want
to get to a regular mailbag question
before we go question is from mark hello
mr knowles love the show i have a
question about prenuptial agreements in
a catholic marriage i'm not currently
dating anyone but all the horror stories
i hear about fathers losing custody of
their children terrifies me i understand
that marriage is a true thing and
therefore divorce is impossible however
i also know that legal divorces happen
often of course it would be ideal that
this not happen
but in light of the fact that it does
would it be acceptable to sign some sort
of prenuptial agreement before marriage
thank you really good question because
it
you
if if marriage were still protected in
public by the state as it had been until
really the 1960s and 70s and even later
then you wouldn't need to worry about
this but because the state is actively
opposed to marriage at this point and
actively destroying marriage and
weakening it
you you probably would have to protect
yourself what i would recommend
if you're worried about it and i did not
sign a prenuptial agreement myself but
if if you are worried about this thing
you would consider
signing a prenuptial agreement that
basically forces you to stay in the
marriage so now in modern america
there's something called no fault
divorce which
renders marriage almost meaningless long
before the court redefined marriage and
attempted to destroy the institution by
enshrining same-sex marriage no fault of
divorce dealt
a much tougher blow at marriage even
than obergefell did
so you could sign a prenuptial contract
that just says we will not have a
no-fault divorce if one of the parties
attempts to bring a no-fault divorce the
the other party has you know that that
party has to pay the other
half a million dollars or something
you could you could sign a contract that
limits
your options and says if
one party uh brings a divorce then the
other party gets everything gets all the
kids gets all the money gets out the
house gets everything that that would be
it's really just occurring to me now
that would be a great way to use this
really ugly tool of the modern world
that weakens marriage namely the
prenuptial agreement use that to
actually strengthen marriage that's
really that's a nice way to be
wise as a serpent and innocent as dove
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bourie supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.